Por que médicos tradicionais não aprovam
a medicina integrativa? Fico muito
confusa. Bem, eu vou tentar aqui falar,
dar uma resposta bem equilibrada que não
seja simplesmente pro sardinha pro meu
lado, tá? Então essa resistência dos
médicos mais ortodoxos ou convencionais
à medicina integrativa tem raízes
complexas. Então temos que analisar isso
por mais de um ponto de vista. Isso
envolve questão científica, ética,
cultural, né? Questão até mercadológica.
Eu vou tentar aqui apresentar uma
análise equilibrada dessa questão. Quais
são então as principais razões que boa
parte dos médicos torce o nariz e
resiste à medicina mais dita
integrativa, né? A medicina ortodoxa ou
convencional critica a integrativa
principalmente pela falta, né, de
evidência científica robusta, né? Muitos
médicos argumentam que tratamentos
integrativos violariam os princípios da
medicina baseada em evidências, né, que
ganhou muita força aí nos últimos 15
anos ou 20 anos, OK? e que também
poderiam violar princípios de ética
médica,
especialmente quando esses praticantes
integrativa incluem protocolos como
homeopatia
ou quântica ou germânica, outros tipos
de modalidade que careceriam de
fundamentação científica sólida. E na
verdade, como um termo medicina
integrativa é um termo extremamente
excessivamente abrangente, ele é um
termo guarda-chuva que eu acho que na
minha opinião deveria ser aos poucos
abandonado, porque você não sabe ouvindo
esse termo do que que se trata de fato,
do que se trata realmente, do que que a
pessoa tá falando quando fala de
medicina integrativa. Pode ser de várias
coisas diferentes. Cada um faz a
medicina integrativa de um jeito um
pouco diferente, pelo menos existe aí
várias vertentes. Então, tem gente que
inclui homeopatia, tem gente que não
inclui, tem gente que inclui quântica,
tem gente que não inclui, tem gente que
inclui medicina germânica, tem gente que
nãoi. Então, realmente fica muito
confuso pra maioria das pessoas você
falar em medicina integrativa quando há
muitas interpretações diferentes do que
poderia ser. A formação médica
tradicional enfatiza protocolos baseado
em evidências, criando uma resistência
cultural a abordagens que não seguem
esses padrões. Então, médicos
convencionais frequentemente vem a
medicina alternativa com desprezo,
considerando retrocesso científico.
Porém, o que muitos médicos
convencionais ortodoxos não consideram é
que essa medicina dita baseada em
evidências que eles tanto veneram, ela
tá altamente contaminada com problemas
de interesses econômicos e políticos. Já
foi provado mais de uma vez que existe
corrupção dentro de várias revistas
médicas, até algumas muito conceituadas.
Vamos falar aqui a verdade. Problemas
éticos existem em todas as medicinas.
dentro da medicina integrativa existe
uma falta de consenso em muitas
práticas, sendo que muitas dessas
práticas têm estudos científicos, sim,
comprovando, mesmo que não sejam estudos
muito grandes, já que não tem aí
financiamento forte da BIC Farma,
enquanto outras formas, né, de
integrativa fazem práticas completamente
sem nenhum tipo de comprovação. Então
esse é um ponto que a gente tem que
colocar aqui. Existe o risco de
pacientes abandonarem também tratamentos
convencionais que não deveriam abandonar
porque acreditam muito na medicina
alternativa.
Porém, nós temos problemas também na
medicina ortodoxa ou convencional.
Práticas fraudulentas não são
exclusividade de nenhuma medicina. Temos
o caso, por exemplo, de um doutor, que
eu não vou mencionar o nome, um
brasileiro que administrou quimioterapia
desnecessária em centenas de pacientes.
Temos aí casos históricos de estudos
antiéticos, como o estudo de Tusk e de
Willow Brook. E temos também práticas
como o upcoding, fraudulento de seguros
e negligência médica. Então, tem vários
aí relatos de problemas éticos também na
medicina ortodoxa. E no meu ponto de
vista e de muitos outros médicos, a
medicina funcional, ela de fato
representa uma evolução. Diferentemente
de outras modalidades alternativas, a
medicina funcional, ela tem
características que distinguem. Primeiro
que tudo que eu procuro fazer aqui é
baseado em ciência. Eu utilizo muito
coleta de dados, estudos para determinar
as razões subjacentes nas condições dos
meus pacientes e enxergar ele como um
todo. Temos também integração na
pesquisa atual moderna com abordagem
personalizada e temos estudos positivos,
especialmente da Cleveland Clinic,
demonstrando que essa medicina funcional
de fato proporciona melhorias na
qualidade de vida. Então, abordagem
holística sistemática focando nas causas
à raiz das doenças e não apenas nos
sintomas, no meu ponto de vista de
vários outros, é muito importante.
Então, é importante a gente avaliar seis
processos fisiológicos centrais:
assimilação, defesa e reparo,
bioenergia, transporte, comunicações,
integridade estrutural. Então isso é uma
maneira muito mais inteligente de
analisar os pacientes e não ficar
repartindo ele em caixinhas, né, em
órgãos e sistemas
e também na medida do possível
personalizar os nossos tratamentos
usando o que tem de mais moderno em
exames, incluindo epigenética, genética,
microbiota, bioquímica e fatores de
estilo de vida, né? Então, a medicina
funcional para mim é o futuro. Ela
representa uma evolução natural da
prática médica por várias razões, porque
ela tem uma eficácia com doenças
crônicas bem superior do que a medicina
mais ortodoxa.
E nós sabemos hoje que 60% dos adultos
americanos t pelo menos uma doença
crônica. E a bordagem funcional, ela é
bem vantajosa, bem efetiva no manejo
dessas condições. E também um lado muito
bonito na medicina funcional é o enfoque
na prevenção e na otimização, né? não
apenas em ficar remediando as doenças e
também um enfoque no cuidado centrado
paciente, promovendo o bem-estar desse
paciente, além de emponderá-lo, né, com
conhecimento para que participe
ativamente da sua jornada de saúde.
Então, a resistência tradicional está
gradualmente cedendo, ela tá
gradualmente diminuindo conforme mais
evidências científicas emergem sobre a
eficácia de várias abordagens
integradas. Então, a chave está em
manter um rigor científico mínimo
enquanto nós expandimos a nossa
compreensão sobre como tratar as pessoas
de maneira integral. Então, o futuro
provavelmente vai ser uma combinação,
uma convergência entre a medicina
ortodoxa, as melhores práticas da
medicina ortodoxa e as melhores práticas
da medicina funcional, criando um modelo
de cuidados mais abrangente e eficaz pro
bem-estar humano, tá? Essa é a minha
percepção e eu acho que nós vamos chegar
lá em algum momento. Um abraço, um beijo
no seu coração. Compartilhe os vídeos,
faça bem. A vida de alguém pode mudar
também no canal do além do se envolva.
Ah.